it's about the cards you've dealt in
life you know
like everybody has their own cards like
people were born into money some people
weren't you know it's all about how you
play your cards you know so whether you
come from a good family or a bad one my
mom died when I was 15. like three days
after my birthday I'm sorry she was sick
for like a year so we knew it was coming
but um
I've been out here on the streets since
I was 15 and 33.
what was your childhood like oh juvenile
hall systems even before yes even before
yeah I was in CPS for like eight years
and she finally got us got me and my
sisters back but um
she died like right after she uh
completed her bachelor's degree in
college for business
so she passed away yeah when I was 15.
yeah
but um after that was juvenile hall
group homes and
Pips and prostitutes
when you start working the streets my
first um 15 15 I was 15. right when my
mom died I was like molested by her
boyfriend
so when she died
before she died I tried to tell her but
she didn't want to believe me so when he
when she died I just left the house
you know thank you
so yeah after she died I left the house
I was like 15 years old I met my first
pimp went to Wilson Way Stockton
got raped got robbed first took left
barefoot in The Vineyards and
after that I really didn't need no pimp
you know because
I just knew that I had to I had it in me
I guess to
at 15 you realize that at 15 I knew I
didn't need nobody like because that guy
wasn't there to help me
you know what I mean I called him after
I was done and like yeah he picked me up
from the gas station after some people
like took me out of The Vineyards you
know they helped me really not him he
drove me back to Fresno and dropped me
off
with no room like no
no kind of like sympathy or empathy
nothing for me like nothing and it was
like that was it and so from there I was
like okay well I know at least where I
can go to make somebody you know what I
mean so after that that's what I started
doing I started meeting people in that
kind of lifestyle and going bouncing out
from different like places different
cities I spent 18 to like 22 on Holt
Boulevard
in a thousand dollar days before the
internet
like not was good back then you know
what I mean
it was like
it was good but have drugs been a part
of your life all the time my mom was a
drug addict my dad my dad was in prison
my whole life so he got out of prison
but like it's always been around drugs
always my mom she snorted Crystal I
think or a crank back then
um I I Dibble I like started Crystal
like when I was like 15 put it down for
a little while back and forth I got with
my kids dad when I was like 17 and I did
like really good home and like a lot of
home and without drugs and or anything
for a long time about five years I would
sneak on the track you know like
sometimes like to try to take a hit
every now and then you know but I would
get beat out of money like left and
right like twenty dollars to this guy he
never come back with my note and then I
have to go back in and you know I didn't
have to sneak it but it's always off and
on but then I had my kids and I put the
dope down completely to have my kids but
I had two kids back to back and I had to
postpartum so bad that
I mean I was just happy to not be
pregnant anymore like I just wanted to
get high and drink or do something like
I I didn't have like a lot of growing I
grew up real fast because my mom died
early so I got pregnant at 21.
and I was pregnant 21 and 22. I felt
like I was pregnant for three years for
some reason I feel like that but um just
having two kids back to back and having
to be sober and then just stressed out
and not having help you know like for
the first year of my kids life I never
gave my babies water because I didn't
know [ __ ] babies drink water I
thought they drank milk you know I
didn't know
because my mom's not there to tell me
you know what I mean my mom's only child
someone have no aunts and uncles
so I there's things like in life that I
didn't know you know what I mean and
I don't know how long did you raise your
kids
my kids well now they're 11 and 12.
my I get okay so my stepmother she's not
kind of greedy or whatever she could my
dad can't have kids no more I was just
like you know she's younger than my dad
she wanted kids and I just have two
fresh babies and you know she was having
like the baby mama blues or whatever but
she called CPS on me CPS worker kind of
like hinted around to me that if there
didn't live with me that there would be
no open case
so because at the time my baby daddy
like kind of instilled in my head that
you know family doesn't take other
family to court we don't do things like
that
or bring the other white people in our
business like the CPS or the cops you
know we don't bring people like that
into our business and um that's the way
I was trained
so when this was happening and CPS one
of these drug tests and they wanted to
come see my house my house was
Immaculate there was nothing they could
say about the care of my kids or the
food but just the neglect they said that
I was
um they said that I left them with a
babysitter on the weekends or whatever I
mean you have to make money people drop
their kids off to the daycare every
[ __ ] day you know what I mean just
because I work a different kind of job
doesn't mean I'm not trying to support
my family
right that's the only thing I know how
to do you're working as a prostitute
yeah
um
but it's like at 15 years old you cannot
get a
you can't get a real job you can't get
emancipated unless you make you know
what I mean like it's hard like the laws
are really hard to where the only thing
I could do at 15 years old with no
[ __ ] no family being a ward of the
Court you know what I mean like what
else can we do sell drugs sell our body
so whatever you know steel I've never
been a thief how far are you in school
11. I have a very high I have a 3.8 GPA
but dropped out at the end of the year I
don't know why I didn't look at it like
this but I went I went to school my
whole life to drop out at the end of the
race the dumbest thing I could have did
I regret it the most because I had a 3.8
like all high school and I never [ __ ]
went past all my exams never even showed
up for school but I mean I show up like
a lunch break and like go to like the
last three or four periods of school and
that I always aged all my classes like
yeah you took a break from drugs when
you had your kids 17 well from like okay
when I was 17 I met my baby daddy and I
like took a break from drugs because he
didn't smoke dope
and 21 I got pregnant the same guy you
know we had two kids and we were selling
dope I was hoeing doing whatever we
could do to make money you know
um I had this we just got into an
apartment and stuff but I was pregnant I
was working at McDonald's at night
walking to work getting off of work at
like 3 30 in the morning four in the
morning walking home and then I was like
too dangerous to be walking to pregnant
you know four months pregnant like walk
in the middle of the night to go to work
and I just told him like you don't want
to sell dope no more because we're
having kids and I understand that you
want to live right but at the same time
we don't have jobs like we have rent
still we still have to take care of our
kids like we still need money so
um
I made them like buy this like old like
Samford and Son truck and he like
recycled like metal and stuff for a
while but this [ __ ] wasn't cutting it
I'm used to prostitute money I'm used to
how many fast money like a lot of it you
know what I mean because I mean
I'm not ugly you know what I mean so I
mean I've had I've had good clients real
good clients I got good clients now and
they're more like my friends my best
friends my boyfriends I some of my
boyfriends be like oh that's your
boyfriend he's my husband he's better
than you you know he gives me a lot more
money than you like he takes care of me
you know like to wear what have you what
have you learned about about men from
doing
all kinds of stuff I mean all kinds of
stuff
all kinds so what kind of stuff you want
to know I mean do you trust men less
after I mean you knew this since you
were 15 so it's really all you've known
men are liars they're dogs but I mean
I'm no better
I feel like I'm no better because
I can't have a normal life like okay at
least you guys have a normal light at
least men have like you know you go home
to your wife and you might come out at
night and play it with us prostitutes
but you go home at night and you got
your home and your kids and your
everything you know I can't even have a
relationship like that because of all
the relations I have with everybody else
I got so many relationships with all
these clients that I might I really
can't have a real relationship in for
myself and there were kind of
relationships that I find
out here in the streets is not love you
know what I mean it's not love it's
about the money it's about the drugs
it's about what you can do for them not
you know not where you want to go or
what you want to do
so right now I guess I'll be um an
independent
um I'm a freelancer
um I don't um I don't have a pimp
I have a boyfriend he's in jail
and before he
I was a hoe before him I'm gonna be a
hoe after him so I don't feel like
that's my pimp you know what I mean
because I mean I would do this without
him I'll do it with them I'll do it with
like any time that was this is what I do
so I hate the fact that like right now
we are fighting domestic violence cases
because
we got into a little altercation stupid
[ __ ] but anyways long story short is the
restraining order is really really
stupid because in the long term we still
come back and mess with each other like
you know what I mean and it's not
physical like you know he's just kind of
crazy he does weird [ __ ] but
it just like affects like a lot of [ __ ]
because like because he's in jail I'll
go through a whole lot of [ __ ] you know
what I mean like I had a whole car
burned down on me before you know like
at least I still have a car you know but
there's a lot of people that don't have
cars like so I've been in this [ __ ] for
like a hell of years like at least 15
plus do you have videos oh a lot of them
are they regulars are they sugar daddies
both I mean what's the difference
there's a lot of overlap there right
what's the difference
I mean a regular okay the right
difference between a regular and the
sugar daddies regular is going to pay
you the same the same amount a sugar
daddy I can call him anytime he's gonna
come through anything I want then my car
got burned down
some girls was hating on me like you
know I was getting some pretty player
prices on some cars flipping them you
know and they got jealous and brought my
car up so this trick or my client
um
he's a good guy you know he went to the
car lot and bought me a car
that's how I drive right now I drive a
2012 Ford Fusion and my payments are 145
a month
if I can't make 145 and I don't know if
I could you know so that's that's good
and it's building my credit too because
I'm on the loan with him
because I don't got no credit I've never
had a [ __ ] job well I've had a
handful of jobs but never lasted more
than five six months you know what I
mean but I'm a workaholic to where like
when I go out when I moved out of state
I work two jobs at one time because I
was so bored and I was clean
so I have a lot of energy I guess yeah
yeah was your drug no we didn't speak
the crystal meth keeps you Crystal
Method leads keeps you moving
and now I've developed a little bit more
habit for alcohol too and it's not and
it's not good because my dad like my dad
likes to drink a whole lot my Grandpa
died
from like sources of the liver on my
birthday when I was three
[Music]
so yeah
in the moment like three days after my
birthday when I was 15.
but um yeah what emotions do you go
through living this lifestyle
[Music]
oh
ups and downs highs and lows every day
like I'm a female so we have female
problems and I'm a prostitute okay so
like rooms and board like [ __ ] like that
if you're really in the streets every
day like I'm really in the streets every
day but I maintain my
um appearance I try to maintain
okay so like if I smoke some dope I
gotta smoke like two blunts or two
joints or something I have to lower you
know level myself out because I know
that my appearance and
I mean even though like I it could look
a lot better I don't look
half as bad as some people you know what
I mean like so it means a lot to make
money like to look like money if you
look like money you make more money and
nobody wants an ugly girl and nobody
wants a girl that sits in sweatpants you
know they have that girl sitting at home
they call them their wife you know
so um
yeah
I don't know I go through a lot of
emotions because you know every day is
different I'm a girl you know sometimes
hygiene you know like if you don't have
a room things are [ __ ] up you know
like emotionally you stay in motels I
stay in a hotel every day I've stayed in
a hotel every day
probably the last 10 years
yeah probably for 10 years 10 years in
motels because and the only reason why
is that I don't have proof of income
I got two good clients right now I got
two sugar daddies real good sugar
daddies and um
they would pay for it you know like off
top no problems but it's like the proof
of income and all that stuff and then
because I haven't had a job I get kind
of nervous talking to people like even
when I seen you I was kind of like you
know like because I'm on drugs and
you're probably not you know what I mean
and I feel like you look at me
differently you know what I mean
so that makes me like insecure or like
less confident to go to do that
interview or to you know like really put
myself out there and try to
see other kind of work
you know because I'm like like when I
went to Missouri and my kids live in
Missouri with their dad and he's a good
dad and um so I don't take like I didn't
ever want to try to petition for custody
of my kids because
you know we don't take each other to
court and the lifestyle I live
I mean even though I wasn't like totally
I mean I had my own apartment I had two
cars and my kids and all this stuff I
was still hoeing you know I mean so it
still brings that kind of Lifestyle
those kind of people around and at the
time it wasn't so bad but you know now
it's kind of like I miss my kids all the
time but
I went six years six years without
seeing my kids because of that my baby
daddy was ashamed of me he said he
didn't want his kids growing up in the
same town his mom being a hoe but it was
cool when I did it with two though so
that hurt my heart
a bit
I went and seen my kids like two years
ago
I get pictures and I get to talk to them
every now and then but he don't like me
to talk to them
but I love my kids there's a lot of
statements that go with this lifestyle
I want my kids I don't have
a real solid connection with the
significant other I don't
I don't have a house
dear friends
no real friends like my clients are my
best friends you know like that they're
the only people I can call on and you
know
like I've been bailed out of jail
and they have nobody to come help me or
put money on my books thank you
but I had a client he was really good to
me too
and we don't get along anymore
he's really mad at me but
he was a good friend to me too like he
had bailed me out of jail recently my
first felony I've ever had like
I'm not a thief I don't I feel like
being a prostitute is probably the
Lesser
uh crime I could commit or like the best
way I could get my money is something I
feel like I'm not robbing nobody
I'm not I'm I'm probably saving lives of
other girls or other people getting
sexually victimized or you know
assaulted by weirdos you know if guys
they couldn't bust their night this
world would be [ __ ] up okay real is
taught I mean if I can't bust my dad
it's a bad problem in my house but
it'll be a lot of angry men in the world
a lot of you a lot of your clients are
married you think
um
they probably are
yeah I mean my I have my my two sugar
daddies they're not they're divorced
like one of them lives with his ex-wife
but they've been divorced for 10 years
and they sleep in separate rooms
but since he's been dedicating a little
bit more time toward me lately
um he's focused more on taking buying he
just sold some property in Mexico and he
wants to move me back he wants to move
me out there to Mexico with him because
his ex-wife found out about me so
um even though they're not together
she's like hey you know
do you think you could actually settle
down with a guy like that see that's the
thing and now I'm addicted to the
lifestyle right I'm a digital lifestyle
like so I don't know like if I could
like I know
um so I told him like there's a lot of
things for me to consider like going out
there
like the fact that you're 74 and you
could die tomorrow
like I don't know how to get you back
across the United States or like you
know there's things that we have to
consider and being like Mexico like
pesos are like nothing compared to
American money I'm used to having
American money I have drug habits I have
lifestyle lavish like I like to look
certain ways I have little you know
money I need money
all the time
like it's never in this Non-Stop
um how old are you I'm 33. 33 he's 70.
34.
74.
yeah we just came back from Mexico
and um I might be getting my titties
down pretty soon
something I really want because you're
paying for it oh yeah between him and my
other client yeah yeah I have one he's
an aerospace mechanic
yeah he lives out of state
good guy too helps me out a lot I've
never dated him have you been in love
before have I been in love before
of course
of course healthy love I don't know I
don't think any kind of love is really
healthy I think love is really the most
like
uh
poisonous thing you can get you know
like that's dangerous like when you
really give your heart and all into
somebody and then get your heart broke
it's [ __ ] up you know what I mean so
but I love hard and that's probably like
a downfall of mine because when she love
somebody
you cannot say that you don't love him
no more so I've been in love with the
guy and then met another guy and fell in
love with him but had so much love for
him I couldn't drop him so I have them
both
and I've brought them both together
in one house one bed one motel room
you know that's my life like
it's crazy what do you think people
outside of this lifestyle don't
understand about girls that do this kind
of work
what they don't understand
I think that they just don't they have a
closed mind for the fit you know I don't
think that they even try to consider to
understand a working girl just because
they never had to sell their [ __ ] or
something you know like
you would if you needed it you would you
would you know just because if your dad
was in prison your mom died I mean if
you were 15 years old like yeah I didn't
have anybody like my grandma my grandma
my dad's mom told like she had my two
nieces living with her but I couldn't
come stay with her at 15. why
my mom just died you know how hurtful
that was to me my grandma's still alive
too she's like 80 something years old
now
and um that hurt my heart like it really
did until this day it does because at 15
I probably needed my family the most you
know and they let me go to the streets
they did
and
my other my my cousins they're like
doctors and wedding planners and you
know have like good jobs and houses and
[ __ ] I'm I'm embarrassed to even go to a
family function I gotta wait for
somebody to die you know before I show
up
because I'm just like
like um I feel like the support of your
family could mean a whole lot and it
really does like in my case it did
because the sexual abuse you went
through as a kid also yeah and then the
fact mom she didn't really believe me
when when um
when I had told her about it because
that was her boyfriend and she was sick
and it's all she knew and I know how she
felt at the time because I'm in a
situation every day in life that I could
sit there and I think like what would my
mom do like oh that's why she did what
she did because she was scared or she
didn't have nothing else to Leach on to
my mom wasn't a hoe like my mom went to
school and [ __ ] like she was a drug
addict which is a drug addict but she
wasn't a hoe but
but when she got clean like going to
school and stuff like she's just never a
hoe so like being a hoe probably wasn't
in my
if my mom was alive I probably wouldn't
have been one you know
because I would probably like care too
much what she would think or
I don't know just didn't want to
disappoint her you know
but not having her around was like
horrible like having my kids without her
like everything's just like without my
mom like
50 I've been online like
I've been alive working longer without
parents than I have had Parents if that
makes sense
so
like everything that I've gotten I can't
say oh yeah my mom taught me that or my
dad taught me that or this or that like
everything I know it's like I've learned
first-hand experience I can burn myself
and that's how it happened like you know
that's how I learned
um I've been like
I went like when I first got like my
kids took I didn't step inside of a
grocery store it was nothing but a
convenience store for like two years
because I was so high
I could look at nobody in the eyes
nobody it's crazy and I finally snapped
out of that little stage and stuff but
I've been like skin like I've never
slept in a tent okay but I sleep in
motel rooms every day and I have to sell
my [ __ ] 100 every day goes to that
motel at least 100 sometimes two or
three because the areas that I like to
stay if I have to go to the Bay Area
I'll spending 300 on the room easy
you know what was the best time of your
life
oh
I mean I've had a lot of good times in
my life you know what I mean like a lot
of good times uh you seem pretty pretty
happy for somebody who's lived such a
rough life ah you got to be nobody wants
a depressed sad huh
you know that's why I like
and I don't really open up to people
like like that you know I don't tell
people my whole life story but this is
my life story you know
but it's easier to laugh it off and
forget about it or just brush it off
like you know what can you do you can't
change it you can really make it better
so I say life is like a poker game like
sometimes like I might have fooled you
huh pull it up in my new car and look at
all this and smiling and [ __ ] but uh
so play the cards you go you know it was
a roughest time
this time getting my kids took
like not took but you know lose my kids
probably that was really rough because
after that
I would like
ah Waist Deep on the drugs and like I
said I wouldn't even walk into a store
or anything for like two years it was
ridiculous like I didn't walk I didn't
go anywhere I had a whole car and never
left the motel room I never left this
like like Figueroa I never left like
where I'm from
it was called Blackstone I'm from Fresno
and it's Blackstone Parkway
I never left Blackstone for two years
and their stores all have been down
Blackstone but I never went into nothing
but other than a liquor store
that's crazy
drugs cigarettes and alcohol that's it
and motel rooms that's where all my
money went and I'm not talking about ten
dollars a hundred dollars I'm talking
about thousands 30 look I pay a hundred
dollars a day in the room
times 30
00 a month easy plus food dope and
everything else car payments cars like
it's a different [ __ ] you know I spent a
lot of money
my daily spend expansion expenses right
now like I have to make 500 a day at
least at least and that's like I won't
wake up with nothing in the morning even
after that I'll wake up still broke
you know and you gotta do it again
you've got to do it all over again put
that [ __ ] face on put these boots on
and this you know but in real life I
don't like this dress like this uh I'm
embarrassed too you know what I mean I
don't really like it you know kind of I
don't feel like my Booty's like the best
or nothing like that like you know but I
get it Shy you know especially being in
public in front of other people that
don't do this or they're not like you
know because this is like frowned upon
this is not uh Vegas or you know Nevada
we don't have cat houses even though we
need one
do you believe in karma hell yeah that's
why I'm not a thief
hell yeah I do
and I don't feel like what I do is um
that 75 year old man he might leave me a
will one day you never know because I
love him you know what I mean I treat
him the same way he treats me you know
you made him happy yeah and that's my
karma like that car these girls brought
my car up a week later I had this car
that's Karma it's always bad but I've
never been a thief and not slime because
karma will catch up to you so fast
without asking for nothing you will get
served quick and uh yeah that's why I've
never been a thief though and that's why
I chose the prostitute over like doing
any other kind of hustling because for
when
selling crack I did that too and I
couldn't my heart couldn't take having
people crying to me coming back for
their rent payment the next day like I
smoked all my rent my kids like you know
like I can't do that like my heart heard
it I wanted to give this guy his money
back you know but that's the game you
know and I just like my heart hurt for
that and I just I was like no I can't do
that I'd rather just suck a dick okay at
least he's smiling when he leaves and he
might call me back you know like selling
drugs is like
I don't know I just did it wasn't for me
like I know how to do it but my heart is
not for it you know
and I'm good at what I do so I'm not
saying like oh I didn't know it like you
know seven years old like what do you
want to be when you grow up like I
didn't know I was gonna be a prostitute
but I'm a good one
I do a good job I always have returning
clients so and I have a lot of [ __ ] to
like well not a lot of [ __ ] to show for
it but I have a lot more than other
people and I'm a freelancer renegade
whatever you want to call it but I mean
sometimes I've I've made stupid
decisions to put all my money into a
guy's pocket
for him to choose up on me like a real
hoe with the next girl with all my money
in his pocket you know
and then I'm left with nothing no gas
you know like this morning like
like this guy had my car like and I've
been seeing him and Stephanie he just
like had my car and the side mirrors
tore off now and there's tape on my
window I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
like this is crazy and like my battery
like how to go buy a new battery this
morning it cost me fifty dollars because
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened to
my battery all of a sudden my battery
just started like dying it was weird I
mean yeah it's [ __ ] up you can't trust
nobody at all so that's why I've never
been a fan of paying a pin
um although it does I'm not gonna lie it
does have it's upset like it does have
its benefits so I you do need a man now
whether I would call him a pimp I
wouldn't because that's a life sentence
right there for nothing because this
girl's gonna hold whether she wants to
or not this I mean the weather not
whether she wants you or not she's gonna
hope if she's in your face and she's
already in this lifestyle that's what
it's going to be that's what it's going
to be period unless she does some
miraculous transformation and goes to
like you know
I have a Betty Ford Clinic I don't know
but uh
that's what it's going to be like drugs
prostitutes pimps that's all hand in
hand it all goes together having a pimp
though is beneficial though because like
especially walking Figueroa you can't
like the girls out there are grimy The
Pimps out there are grimy and you do
need a man you do I the first night on
Figueroa I got my my purse took the guy
paid me for a date where did we get from
the back seat to the front seat he peels
off with my [ __ ] person in the car
like it wasn't violent so I was grateful
that I was safe and that I wasn't hurt
but I was still upset and didn't know
what I was going to tell this man that I
was you know
you know where I've been all day or
where I've been for the last hour and a
half and what I have to show you know so
on my way back I'm taking all the 40 and
50 dates I can get when I know I never
do that I only take a hundred dollars
but because I got robbed and I've been
gone for three hours I need to make up
for that
so I'm snatching every little change I
can get you know degrading my like going
against what I would normally do
so you never say never you know but
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life uh
uh not to be Thief I guess because you
know that's like one of my biggest
things I stick my I'm not a thief and
that things just brings a lot of bad
juju to it and
um life is just precious like the most
important thing is time time so when
you're on a host time don't play
Chloe thank you so much for sharing your
story okay good luck out there this
weekend thank you thanks